as far as action-packed shows from the
1990s go xena warrior princess is one of
the best
xena played by lucy lawless was given
her own spin-off after a brief recurring
role in hercules the legendary journeys
creator robert tapert recognized how
popular she was with audiences and xena
warrior princess quickly became a cult
favorite running for six seasons from
1995 to 2001. the swords and sandals
epic doesn't just have the hero facing
off against evil warlords or ares the
god of war however xena often battles
demons and monsters too and considering
the show was produced in the 1990s some
of the practical effects looked pretty
great it seems pretty clear that xena is
ripe for a reboot especially in a time
where wonder woman made 800 million
dollars at the box office when it
debuted back in 2017.
so why hasn't a xena reboot happened yet
unsurprisingly xena fans have always
been vocal about their love for the hero
especially since many saw the clear
subtext in the show that she had a
romance with gabrielle played by renee
o'connor in fact their relationship was
going to be the main focus of a new xena
reboot in 2015 from lost alumni javier
griot marswa for nbc brio martial wrote
on his tumblr page in 2016 there is no
reason to bring back xena if it is not
there for the purpose of fully exploring
a relationship that could only be shown
subtextually in first run syndication in
the 1990s he also noted that the reboot
would have some kind of social relevance
in its story saying
it will also express my view of the
world which is only further informed by
what is happening right now
unfortunately in 2017 grio marswa parted
ways with the xena reboot due to
creative differences with nbc
however grio marswa told the mary sue
that he remains hopeful xena will return
to the screen at some point in the
future explaining i truly hope that the
alchemy of creative elements that has to
come together to make possible either a
reboot or revival of this amazing
property will someday coalesce
when the news broke that the xena reboot
wasn't going forward at nbc the
network's former entertainment president
jennifer salke explained to the
hollywood reporter nothing is happening
on that right now we looked at some
material we decided at that point that
it didn't warrant a reboot however it
wasn't all negative as selkie pointed
out that xena is a beloved property that
might be rebooted someday it all depends
on who's at the helm of the reboot as
sulky explained i'd never say never on
that one because it's such a beloved
title but the current incarnation of it
is dead i need someone to come in with a
point of view about what they want to do
in 2018 the pilot script for the reboot
leaked online to the xena movie campaign
facebook page but fans in the comments
were disappointed about what the script
contained
for instance one user lamented that
hercules had been changed into a
heartless mercenary in the script others
felt that it had potential especially
where xena and gabrielle's relationship
was concerned
fans also pointed out that a new xena
project without lucy lawless wouldn't
feel right as for whether the star would
ever come back to the role the answer is
yes and we all have terminator dark fate
to thank lawless told yahoo
entertainment in july 2019 that seeing
linda hamilton return as sarah connor
made her wonder why she couldn't do the
same with xena she revealed i saw linda
being amazing and i'm like why can't we
do that bring back me and renee o'connor
and reboot xena while lawless did admit
that filming all the action wasn't her
favorite part of making xena warrior
princess she said she'd happily do it
for a big screen project explaining i
always hated the action and i don't want
to live that life but for a movie i can
do a little bit lawless even suggested
that a cinematic outing for xena could
easily set up a brand new hero
explaining if it's about handing over
the baton to junior xena or whatever if
you need mine and renee's help to do
that let's talk lucy lawless is in and
so are the fans nbc just needs to find a
writer with a new vision
sounds simple enough check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
tv shows are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you